well America has always been a country
of innovation and dynamism
entrepreneurship and I think that one of
the things that has made our country
great too is its heterogeneous
population where people come here from
all over the world and quite often the
people who do live their own nation with
and come to an unknown destination like
the United States are inherently
adventurous so we've had that
adventurous spirit that then has
embedded itself collectively in the
American consciousness I think all of
those are factors combined have made it
possible for us to be in the forefront
of change social change as we had to
accommodate people from different
societies and different religions and so
forth and also changes that have taken
place in innovative science because
America has had the best university
system in the world for a long time and
so we have been innovators not only in
discoveries as proven by Nobel prizes
and chemistry and physics and that sort
of thing but we've been able to put that
into practical application with new
gadgets that people admire
we've had a serious problem in our
country in recent I'd say few decades in
becoming more inclined toward
consumption and gratification oh how
much we own rather than have a spirit of
innovation and dynamism and producing
new products it was in the 1970s that
our nation first became a consumer
nation that is we bought from foreigners
more than we sold to foreigners and
increasingly that has been a blight on
our economic system increasingly every
year and now we have an enormous trade
deficit that is we buy from foreign
nations particularly China and others a
lot more than we sell them and it means
that they are producing the products
that we use and we used to be the main
producer of our goods to be sold to to
our competitive nations that were fairly
well-off and particularly to the
countries that were very poor that's
changed now so I think we've lost the
competitive edge that we had a number of
years ago